hey guys hi it's me ross matthews and my
brother eric is joining us flew all the
way here from california to be on the
show eric while you're here we thought
we might hit some uh sibling
superlatives we haven't seen these
questions so we are going to work these
out in real time you ready i'm ready
[Music]
okay question one out of the two of us
who got into more trouble growing up
yeah obviously me yeah what was the
worst thing you ever did i can remember
throwing apples at the peavines going by
oh the tractors yeah yeah and broke a
window and then a cop state patrolman
chases all around the neighborhood i at
least got to teach you what not to do
with all of my screw-ups so you're
welcome i rode my bike to the um grocery
store to get candy once i got grounded
for a week that's the worst thing i ever
did that's the worst
no wonder
who's more likely to lie about watching
or reading the others work i don't think
i would either one of us lie about it
we're proud of each other we root each
other on support each other i might copy
it you know trademark infringer yeah
yeah he does a great ross impression all
right number three who's the better cook
you i would say i cook more often you do
cook tomorrow yeah i love a really good
pasta with fresh veg
who is the favorite child that's a
terrible question i mean how dare you
put that on there that's that's rude and
i refuse to answer it
who is more likely to forget the other's
birthday never that would never happen
that would never happen they were the
first one
to call each other on her birthday yeah
and sing in horrible horrible voices
well yeah not yours yourself i came out
of my mother's womb like a human karaoke
machine it was like too much like can
you tone it down ross who is funnier
well that depends on the moment or
depends on the joke yeah
you're quicker
much quicker i can be a little rauncher
no that's not true either look everyone
that's what i'd look like if i were
straight
who's more likely to forget the name of
a famous actor
you're kidding me i don't even know my
name i'm like an encyclopedia of pop
culture i know yeah nobody can compete
with you thank you
who has better fashion sense i'm getting
all the good ones
he obviously look at him i mean
beautiful i like your sweater it's yours
i know a jerk
who has better taste in tv
you do you do that's not true oh 100
true only two shows football and another
one what's the other one uh gold rush
yeah but it's a sh he watches like a
highbrow documentary tv i watch 90 day
fiance all right so you have better
taste in tv who is more likely to talk
about a podcast they're listening to
definitely you yeah well no i only
listen to yours anyway
what podcast is that
straight talk with ross matthew
available everywhere
yes i am the youngest thank you for
noticing i can't even remember the name
of this podcast
[Music]